relationship advice yeah obviously this
is duncan
this is a hot tub time machine duncan yo
it's the king of the stadium
brandon start over we cannot say that
about this guy it's gonna break his
heart
no he knows his teeth are [ __ ] up he's
been he's been through some struggles i
think he might know
him no he knows he knows his teeth you
know harnesses this video when you have
[ __ ] up teeth and cinnamon and the
first thing somebody says you have
[ __ ] up teeth dog
dude he knows nobody wants to get bit by
him
i'll tell you what one thing you can't
do is bite pizza perfectly round like i
can dude
yeah if you look at my [ __ ] ig store
you'll see well really we'll put the
picture in dude
perfectly round bite i didn't even
notice that someone commented on him
chompers on you no he he bites it looks
like a goddamn great white took a bite
out of your [ __ ] cheeks
yes you got serial killer teeth somebody
said look at that
oh you got them richard ramirez teeth
okay i like you i love your teeth man i
think you can do whatever you want with
them yeah i think it makes you unique
what up guys it's your boy dave from
pittsburgh um and i need some
relationship advice
uh i've been with my girl for about 10
years now
um and when we met we both loved to
party like most people oh yeah well
familiar with meth i had some good times
but i ended up with an addiction
um and so did she uh by the grace of god
she's got three years clean
and i'm coming up on a year let's go one
year longer
anyway let's go analyze the question my
girlfriend has a degree in psychology
loves helping people currently she's a
counselor at a methadone clinic
the problem i have with that is the
stress she's under
every single day i'm sure you can
imagine what these people are putting in
through telling her you know she comes
home every day
just suck dry i mean just
yep i'll be emotional for you mom where
i think she hates it
not that she hates it but she hates it
how do i tell her i think that's the
wrong career path i don't want to come
off
mean like i don't support her but i
think she should choose a different
field maybe something where she can
still help but
not necessarily in that way and then we
got to hear a sign off
gang gang nod nod oh yeah that heroine
that's that heroin that heroin dream
state baby
hell yeah dude i went with a buddy of
mine to the uh
to the jazz festival uh in new orleans a
few years back and he was
just aged out the whole time and he
[ __ ] literally slept to like
seven bands and got [ __ ] sun
poisoning
drugs are [ __ ] man but it was
unbelievable
what were you doing the whole time just
rejoining yourself
yeah totally hey man you want a bear
yeah and then finally i guess he just
wants to rest you know
kidnap and we didn't have any things and
some people thankfully some people some
[ __ ] hippies that built some big
kites and would lean those against them
to
block the sun that some was tearing his
ass up but that was four bands in dude
that was already after elton john
and uh oh and they're long and sugar ray
had done a return dude you lucky it
wasn't a grateful dead
concert yeah that boy would have been
jerky
he would have been just dead
he would have been looking great he
would have been ungrateful we've been
having conversations with jerry garcia
bro yeah and he was out there uh
but look man i dude yeah i think it's
hard to have a job in that sort of
industry especially these days man
people just get so zapped out
but also if if she's getting money and
that's like her thing she wants to help
people are you going to tell her no
yeah and also i don't know if you have a
job either david i don't mean to bring
that up but
you don't want to you know
he doesn't you don't want to
you don't want to look a grocery horse
in the mouth you know what i'm saying
so you don't make a video
video on a tuesday afternoon and have a
job bro
he could be an artist yeah you're right
he's playing
but what i'm saying is look man uh
congratulations on coming up on a year
congratulations on your girls three
years man
yeah it's big time it's big of her to
try and give back look i think she'll
know when it's time to quit i don't know
if it's you know it's
i don't know if it's up to him yeah i
don't know if it's affecting you but
it's nice that you shared it with us to
just try and even get it off your chest
a little bit
yeah and can you can you bite a piece of
pizza and send it in
y'all gonna be fine man but don't look a
freaking grocery horse in the mouth baby
dog
don't look a grocery horse in the mouth
baby you don't want to look a produce
pony
in the yapper you know what i'm saying
dog you gotta [ __ ] make sure
you got that cereal and milk yeah i'm
gonna make your shits together
[Music]